during the dehydration experiment ethene
gas and unreacted ethanol passed through
the tube into the water the ethene was
quantitatively collected as a gas but
the unreacted ethanol was not explained
this observation in terms of the
intermolecular forces between water and
each of the two gases and just to be
clear what they're talking about we can
go to the original setup that they gave
us at the beginning of this problem and
what they're saying is is through this
when they warm up they'll react this the
catalyst and the ethanol in here some of
that ethanol gets converted into Athene
but not all of it does in fact part of
this experiment we saw that we don't
have a perfect we have a 60 point
something percent yield and so you have
a combination of ethanol and ethene gas
going through this tube it cools down
then it goes through this water and
they're saying it looks like we're only
seeing or we're primarily seeing the
ethene gas here how come we're not
seeing the ethanol gas and the reason
and I'll just paraphrase it right now
and then I'll write it down is that the
ethanol the ethanol gas is much more
dissolvable in the water because ethanol
is a polar molecule water is a polar
solvent so it's going to it's going to
it's going to dissolve much better in
water than the ethene which isn't a
polar molecule so let me let me write
this down
so the ethene will kind of bubble
through while the ethanol can actually
dissolve so let's write this down so
oops I'm having trouble all right there
you go so explain this observation in
terms of intermolecular forces between
water and each of the two gases so we
could write ethanol ethanol is polar
polar so it dissolves in water
much better than then Athene which is
non non polar and so we could say
something like so ethanol ethanol and
water and water will have hydrogen bonds
will have hydrogen bonds hydrogen bonds
you can even diagram it out if you like
the ethanol is right over here
so you have your oxygen and then you
have your hydrogen and then you have
your c2h5 this side over here this is
going to be partially negative this is
going to be partially positive this is
going to oxygen is more electronegative
than carbon the difference is less than
between oxygen and hydrogen but this is
also going to be partially positive
maybe not as partially positive it's on
this side right over here and so when
you have water molecules so this is a
water molecule right over here where
this was partially positive charges
partially negative charges you're going
to have the hydrogen bonds hydrogen
hydrogen bonds and so the ethanol is
going to dissolve much better you could
the ethene isn't polar and will only
have induced dipole forces acting on it
so let me write this ethene ethene is
not polar is not polar and so are to
take so we'll only have induced dipole
interactions induced dipole and maybe
well I could say dipole because well the
water is the water is polar and even
though ethene is
metrical molecule it has that double
bond it has no net polarity there are
parts of the ethene molecule that are
going to be a little bit more negative
than others in particular when you look
at when you look at the carbons over
here they're a little bit more
electronegative than the hydrogen's and
so ethene is not polar so we'll only
have induced dipole or I guess we could
also say just dipole interactions
interactions interactions with polar
water polar water and so this is why so
this is why ethene won't dissolve as
well
ethene won't dissolve as well and
bubbles through and bubbles through
ethanol dissolves ethene bubbles through
cuz it's not it doesn't have a strong
interactions with the water